[MUSIC PLAYING]
If we were to
imagine what it would
look like to build
a whole self at MIT,
I think it starts with music.
Music is where you find
your personal expression.
Music is what
opens new horizons.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I was very, very
excited when Fred Harris
contacted me to be a virtual
visiting artist at MIT.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Anat Cohen is a
treasure of a musician.
She crosses many
boundaries, plays
jazz clarinet, also saxophone,
got interested in choro.
Choro is a type
of Brazilian music
that grew up around
Rio de Janeiro
in the early 20th century.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I got to write an arrangement
of a Brazilian choro called
"Cheguei."
And they recorded
it and performed it
in a virtual concert.
And I got to attend a
couple of rehearsals
and work with the students.
And it was a great
experience for me.
And I hope-- by
some of the smiles
I could see that those aha
moments were really nice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I could see how a
student went from point A
to point B. How the
progress was made.
How more relaxed they were.
How they may have
taken my advice,
but also how to just
work on their craft
and achieve the next level.
It felt like a very
inclusive process.
What's most impactful is
like the direct feedback.
We'd play something and there
would be those tiny things
that you might not
notice if you were just
listening to a recording
and try to emulate it.
She'd be, like, oh, you know,
you're rushing a little bit,
or she'd be, like, oh,
you have to introduce
this slightly different
swing that you're maybe not
used to playing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I met all these incredible
students of MIT and realizing
how important music is for them.
How serious they are about it.
And how dedicated they are.
And playing and keep
being involved and playing
with other musicians is
important for their existence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]